das ist die letzte folge dieser früher
beliebten serie
denn nicolas meyer ist durchgedreht of
three durchgedrungen
[Musik]
ein kalter tropfen kondenswasser lief
über meine haut und ich liebte es hat
mich wahnsinnig an unsere gemeinsame
lektüre von 50 es ist eine
aneinanderreihung und sie haften
charakteren die sich nur in hipster
blase liegt das programm ja ich sage
jetzt mal ganz kurz worum es geht
nämlich um zwei junge frauen in irland
die beide so locken word veranstaltungen
machen und sie sollen fotografiert
werden von einer etwas älteren
fotografen die mit einem schauspieler
verheiratet ist und zwischen diesen vier
leuten entwickelt sich so eine art am
hut ich finde es geht irgendwie um
nichts
aber das interessante ist doch
eigentlich wie ist die stimmung die das
ganze ab bildet da sind männlich und
redselig natürlich weil sie auch sehr
modern sind also alle möglichen
kommunikationsmittel werden ineinander
verwoben wir haben jets wir haben e
mails wir haben sms wir haben gespräche
in seiner struktur bedient es eine
bestimmte man kann auch vielleicht etwas
schärfer sagen konsumhaltung die für
mich sehr viel mit netflix zu tun hat
das heißt du kannst das sehr angenehm im
moment konsumieren und dann kann es auch
wieder aufhören und wieder einschalten
und wieder da weitermachen wo wir stehen
geblieben willst es bietet nichts über
das hinaus was an der oberfläche
geliefert wird jürgen habermas würde
sagen die transzendentale sierung von
literatur herzlich an
ich war so gebe ich zu aber für mich ist
das buch ein zeit diagnostisches buch
das bildet ab wie junge menschen deren
leben wir beide gar nicht mehr richtig
kennen in den tag hinein denken finden
leben und deswegen hat es doch seine
berechtigung einfach um an etwas
teilzunehmen was uns normalerweise
verschlossen bleibt
und wenn du so lange redest du hast
jetzt zehn minuten gericht wegen der
ebenso hier schon vorstellen raus ich
dir gleich vorlesen will zum thema
denken
zb ein kantate ich bin immer noch dran
ein buch muss die antworten auf die
fragen die es stellt nicht in einer
natürlich darf man auch mal inne
ich möchte gerne zur textarbeit
übergehen
sprechen wir zum beispiel mal war dann
vorher gewinnerseite am anfang einer
ausführung als ich noch jung war
gesprochen haben gefühlen haye sagte ich
ich will dich wirklich und ich spürte
wie er nicht so süß und eifrig manche
leute denken so philipp es ist schnell
geschrieben ist es gut lesbar ist sehr
humorvoll es geht ja auch darum zu
zeigen dass diese junge generation in
bildern von klischees sich bewegt im
duell clips über die nächste ebene und
erklärt mir dann die großartig sagte
oxonitsch lebens und du sagst ja hand
ein paar nicht schreiben aber sie zeigt
und wie verloren wir an einer sesseln es
ist ein engel der gradlinigkeit und
schlichtheit stilistisch engel der
gradlinigkeit und schlichtheit watt ist
kaputt das ist einfach 500 seiten
gequassel engel der gradlinigkeit ich
werde damit das ist eine insel folgen
dieser früher beliebten serie den liga
ist durchgedreht officially durchgedreht
[Musik]